At the 100th Anniversary
of the Chinese Communist Party in 2021,
Chinese President Xi
Jinping outlined his vision
for the Chinese Dream.
We will achieve the goal of building
a great modern socialist
country in all respects
and fulfill the Chinese Dream
of national rejuvenation.
The fact that China and Xi Jinping
talk about a China Dream
really reminds us that great powers
need to have grand narratives
in the same way that the United States
and the narrative about
the American Dream.
To make that China Dream a reality
and achieve the great rejuvenation,
Chinese leaders believe they must have
the world's most powerful military.
A strong country
must have a strong military,
as only then can it guarantee
the security of the nation.
The Party came to recognize
the irrefutable truth
that it must build a
people's military of its own.
China's military power
has been growing at an incredible speed
over the last 20 years.
In terms of fear and influence,
we absolutely know that China
wants to be dominant in Asia.
So there is a target to get to that point,
to be a military that is a peer
to the greatest militaries
in the world by 2035.
The competition for
influence is a global one.
And through a multi-decade trajectory
filled by planning, money, and pragmatism,
China's building a military that allows it
to shape the 21st century,
just as the US shape the 20th.
The most interesting question
when it comes to China's growth
and what spurred the growth is actually,
you don't have to look back
50 years, 40 years, 30 years.
Actually, most of these
changes have happened
in the past 25 years.
So if you go 25 years ago,
the Chinese economy was
smaller than France's economy.
They took up 3% of global GDP.
They had a military that you could hardly
even call it a military, right?
A Navy that couldn't
sail beyond the coast.
Until second half of 1990s,
the Chinese defense budget
was absolutely negligible. at some point
less than $15 billion,
2.5 million troops.
But now, China is either
the second or third
most powerful military in the world.
And it's got there largely as always
through spending a lot of money.
Thanks to a 740% increase
in military spending
as well as elite focus,
they've now built one of the
most formidable militaries
that this world has ever seen.
China's defense expenditures
have multiplied by 12 times since 2000.
And while America's military budget
is nearly four times that of China's,
it does not mean that the US' military
is four times as powerful.
And that's because of
different objectives.
The United States is
trying to project power
all around the world.
That is extremely costly.
The US spends huge amounts of their money
on the global war for
terror in the Middle East
in the past two decades.
And of course, China's lowers
the defense construction cost
and it has cheaper man power.
That budget of the United States,
it's used for the United States to act
as the global guardian
of the Labor International Order.
Instead, the smaller budget of China
is mostly concentrated in one region.
We have hundreds of bases overseas.
China has one.
So they're really promoting
their military power regionally.
And so that's one way that they can
out compete the United States.
I have been very, very straightforward
and blunt with President Putin.
We will impose the most severe sanctions
that have ever been imposed,
economic sanctions.
When the US is distracted elsewhere,
whether it's over the Ukraine issue now
or the war on terror for
two decades beforehand,
the United States cannot
compete with China.
Countries like the US, the UK, Australia,
European countries
overlook the understanding
of China's strategic culture.
And we didn't want to accept the fact
that while we were trading with China,
China was growing militarily.
To understand the magnitude
of China's determination in
achieving its national goals,
look no further than the
Belt and Road Initiative,
china's trillion dollar
global infrastructure plan
and the centerpiece of
President Xi Jinping's
foreign policy.
The Belt and Road Initiative
is one of the big Chinese economic plans
to build power and influence in the world.
The United States could have
done 10 of those, right?
But instead we fought
the war in Afghanistan.
And while the US and the EU
are busy policing the world,
China has focused on
building infrastructure.
And when it comes to the military,
it has had the same laser focus.
The Chinese were actually
extremely pragmatic
in deciding how to go about matching
its military capacities
and increasing them,
so that it could challenge US dominance.
And they did so basically with weapons
that are much cheaper to produce
than the things that they destroy.
Of course, there are certain narrow areas
where Chinese are more advanced.
These areas include the
hypersonic missiles.
What we saw was a very significant event
of a test of a hypersonic weapon system,
and it is very concerning.
I think I saw in some of the newspapers
that they used the term Sputnik moment.
What they're really,
the US, is really saying
is that these hypersonic missiles
could change the game.
China is investing in hypersonic missiles
principally to show the rest of the world
that it's capable of developing
cutting edge military technologies.
Because of the name,
people focus the hypersonic part
and how fast they go,
but actually the biggest issue
when it comes to defenses
is that they can fly very low
because of the circular
nature of the Earth.
If you have a radar system,
you don't see it until
close to the last minute,
which makes it difficult to intercept.
The broader strategic issue
that China is more advanced in this area
than the United States is
brings up a lot of anxiety about
how the United States
technologically is falling behind.
They shown this on parade in 2019
and the Americans are only expected
to have a first battery of similar missile
for testing in 2023.
So that's incredibly,
that's an incredible lead.
And while the US is trailing China
in hypersonic technology,
China is quickly closing the gap
when it comes to Naval Forces.
In 2015, China published a white paper
on China's military strategy,
where the Chinese elites stated
that China needs to move beyond
an old fashioned, traditional
mentality-based on land power.
The Americans understand that the Chinese
are gradually winning the arms race.
They're simply building more
ships than the American can.
The Americans have been
losing their manufacturing
for generations.
The best example is ship building.
China is the country with the biggest
commercial ship building
industry in the world.
China basically builds 40%
of the ships in the world.
The US and its European
allies build about 1%.
It allows the Chinese to produce ships
at an extraordinary rate,
and to overtake or to
match the US very quickly,
if they wish to.
Once you get into wartime,
those advantages, they really determine
the ability of the US to win
the first and second
World Wars for the Allies.
Operating day and night
on a 24-hour mass production schedule,
America giving wings
to the greatest armada
of fighting ships the
world has ever known.
Many analysts nowadays
believe that China is already capable
of winning a short-term conflict
within the First Island Chain,
which is this line that
goes from the south of Japan
through Taiwan, down to the Philippines
and the South China Sea.
In addition to a state of the art Navy
as well as their hypersonic missiles,
China may also have an edge when it comes
to how wars are fought
in the 21st century.
One of the most worrying areas
of Chinese development
has been cyber warfare.
As much as we know,
the Chinese have the biggest
cyber forces in the world.
It's important to understand
that the Chinese started
to prioritize cyber warfare
and the information warfare in general
very early in 1990s.
They understood that the
key of American advantage
was the information advantage.
And to win, they needed to
destroy this American advantage.
They've been able to accelerate
their arms development programs
by gaining intelligence
on US weapons systems.
With cyber, nobody's ever quite sure
about what the other side's capability is
until it's been used.
And once it's been used, it's gone
and you have to develop something else
because it can be dealt
with once it's known.
Cyber immediately takes you on
to the question of
artificial intelligence.
And Vladimir Putin famously said,
whoever wins that competition
will rule the world.
And the ideas that once you develop AI,
they can either assist or
replace weapon systems.
And this emphasis on cyber warfare
and artificial intelligence
tell us how extremely relevant
continues to be the writing of Sun Tzu,
and in particular, "The Art Of War",
where concepts like disruption, deception,
know your enemy, win without fight,
remain important.
Ultimately, China's powers
wrapped up in how much influence
their military and their economy have.
But one question still remains,
what does China, as well
as Xi Jinping, really want?
US-China relations is based on
our understanding of the Taiwan issue.
The United States keeps the seventh fleet
and other military forces in the area
to preserve the status quo.
Xi Jinping has kind of decided
that he doesn't like this perpetual
de facto independence of Taiwan
and he wants to start bringing
Taiwan back into the fold.
The way that the Communist Party
originally wanted to do that
was through peace reunification.
So close economic and cultural ties
would convince the people of Taiwan
to voluntarily be a part of the PRC.
That is not happening.
The last polls is only 6%
of the people of Taiwan said
that they wanted to be a part of the PRC.
And so now in Mainland China
there's serious discussion about,
"Well, if we can't do this peacefully,
domestic Chinese law tells us
it's time to do it by force."
The cross trades relation is a kind
of stable condition under
the unstable situation.
Unification is the final
puzzle piece for China.
China is trying to intimidate
Taiwan and the United States
as well as the other
countries in this region.
There is a widespread belief
that over the next 20 to 30 years,
China will be so powerful militarily
that they will be able
to grab Taiwan very easy.
This is still a question mark,
because regardless of the power of China,
regardless of the fact
that there is a huge
military gap between China and Taiwan,
it is extremely difficult for China
to put boots on the ground in Taiwan.
And this is because of the complex
urban geography of Taiwan.
It's because of the few entry points
on the coast of Taiwan.
Taiwan will be able to mobilize
a great amount of military reserve.
It will be able to mobilize its population
against an invasion.
And so regardless of the power of China,
Taiwan might be China's Vietnam.